good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation it's always a treat
to do stuff with the Exploratorium I was
a biology student in the 50s at Stanford
majoring in ecology and evolution and I
only did one silly little field study
and went off and did other things the
army and so on but I've wanted to keep
track of what's going on in biology
ecology evolution and the rest of it the
rest of my life and turned out the easy
way to do that was just to watch what
Edward o Wilson was up to the one
revolution in science after another came
from his work starting with well
starting with his work on ants basically
figuring out the great mysteries of ants
how they communicate how the social
insects function but then he would step
right outside and do things like Island
biogeography which basically
revolutionized ecology population
biology and the understanding of
extinction processes he went on to
things like sociobiology highly
controversial at the time later proved
to be quite right he introduced the term
biodiversity and made that as a nice
statement of a generalized goal that
conservation is all about he's done this
time after time and the treat of the
current book the social conquest of
Earth is at the age of 82
you saw it off and done it again we'll
hear about it right now Edward o Wilson
[Applause]
thank you
flexors zipper Rob dr. brand Stewart
ladies and gentlemen friends colleagues
and Paul Gauguin's 1898 Tahitian
masterpiece which he did you intended to
be his last work before he committed
suicide he gave the title in the upper
left hand corner as three famous
questions where do we come from
what are we where are we going these
happen to be the central questions of
religion and philosophy through
millennia we've sought and argued about
the first two questions where do we come
from and what are we will we ever be
able to solve them sometimes it seems
not yet perhaps we can religion will
never provide the answers the reason
that each organized religion and there
are hundreds of them has its own
different creation story in competition
with all the others each creation story
was written in times and circumstances
when the author's knew almost nothing
about the universe the planet life on
Earth and the prehistory of the human
condition
and each considers its creation story in
answer to where do we come from and what
are we to be the correct one and also
set and stone and superior to all of the
others
each was born from the dreams and
speculations of shamans and prophets
they cannot all be correct no two can be
correct not in fact is consistent with
our growing knowledge of the universe
the planet life on Earth or the
prehistory of the human condition we
also look in vain at
academic philosophy for the answer to
the great question the great riddle
despite its normal normal purpose and
history despite its effectiveness and
training the mind to inquire and think
logically professional secular
philosophy long ago gave up trying to
answer the overall question what is the
meaning of life most of the history of
philosophy is true with the wreckage of
theories of the conscious mind after the
decline the logical positivism in the
middle of the last century and the
attempt to join science and logic into a
closed system philosophers have
scattered and it is electoral by a
diaspora into those areas not yet
colonized by science in the like
intellectual history mathematics
foundational mathematics ethics and most
profitably problems of personal
adjustment
by default in the solution of the great
critic riddle has been left to science
to knowledge of the real world that can
be tested and shared with every person
what science promises and is already
supplied in heart in part is the
following there is a real creation story
of humanity and one only and it is not a
myth it's being worked out and tested
and enriched and strengthened
step-by-step what I'm going to attempt
now is to tell you that story it comes
together from multiple disciplines from
molecular genetics neuroscience and
evolutionary biology to ecology and
archeology and psychology and all the
way to history and has come from my own
gleaning of the primary literature
especially in the last 20 years from
premier journals and it is the piecing
together like a jigsaw puzzle that I've
been attempting and not an idea that
just sprang from my head to make that
effort let me first define the very high
level of social complexity called youth
sociology you means well literally
gentle Pleasant but it's also we take it
to mean true of the central condition
this is the existence of groups over
multiple generations in which adult
members rear the young collectively
and very longevity a reproduction of
themselves or both in ways that enhance
the complexity and success of the social
system there are countless thousands of
animal species that form groups of
different kinds and some are dramatic
like the gorillas but almost all of the
gorillas another animal
fall short of eusociality they lack a
consistent division of reproduction and
labor based upon altruistic behavior I
have before you now the to social
conquerors of Earth in fact true
eusociality has originated on the
terrestrial part of the planet only very
rarely I count some two dozen times
without the history of life of which we
have record variously and several kinds
of insects and crustaceans twice in the
mole-rats of Africa and then once in
human line it doesn't happen at all
until quite late in evolutionary time
from the early measles oeq about a
hundred and fifty million years ago when
it did occur then it produced species
that dominate the environment the ants
and termites alone even though there are
approximately fifteen thousand own
species only a tiny fraction of the 1
million known species of insects make up
in most habitats in the world as much as
half of all of the biomass they
absolutely rule the invertebrate land
and living environment and humans of
course of the dominant of dominance
so hence in most parts of the world
weigh as much as four times all of the
vertebrates put together all of the
landlords birds amphibians reptiles
mammals as indicated in this little
diagram showing as a Jaguar and then the
relative size of the biomass of all the
ants found in the same locality in this
case in the era in the Amazon and
finally and strikingly it is a very this
very small array of evolutionary lines
that have been the most persistent
through evolution once acquired then the
matter was set
who is going to rule the world so to
speak in terms of dominance and
ecological impact on the rest of life so
here are then are the two important
mysteries of evolutionary biology
relevant to the origin of eusociality
and hence of the condition the human
condition these are two questions not
asked heretofore combined knowledge by
biologists or any sciences just didn't
occur to them apparently ever to think
that this is what we need to know first
before we can explain where we came from
and what we are the first that youth
sociality being given given that is so
successful why is it so very rare and
why did it take so long to originate an
evolution and then the second great
question largely unanswered that I'll be
addressing it is what is the force and
evolution what kind of selection
pressure drove it this is the setting we
need to address in order to understand
the origin of humanity and these are the
questions that biologists and answer our
bodies have not yet answered it did take
a long time during the Paleozoic period
400 to 250 million years ago the coal
forests of the earth teamed with insects
of great variety by that time some of
the major groups like the beetles the
mayflies dragonflies and cockroaches had
appeared and they were radiating into
many species they were very very
prominent but there were many other
groups of insects which went extinction
to extinction with the Permian crash of
250 million years ago and they included
in section ever heard of paleo Dixie
Opera
illa trop try and so on first thus the
first great covering of the world by
insects yielded no use sociality that we
are aware of and vertebrate life are
similarly very tardy throughout the
Mesozoic we had dinosaurs of great
variety many of which were bipedal and
had free hands and yet and they had the
capacity no more no less than some of
the primates to develop a larger brain
they never did if they had the dinosaur
roids of the Mesozoic who took over the
world instead of waiting for the mammals
to do it might have looked like the
creature on the right the first ants and
termites appeared but in the Mesozoic ah
and then slowly built up to a dominant
position by the early part of the of the
Cenozoic some 65 million years ago they
began to take over in big time now this
is the evolutionary maze to explain what
happened are better usually did not
happen let me offer the metaphor of the
evolutionary maze species proceeds
through the maze step-by-step led by
action of natural selection generation
by generation all the genomes they
possess and the environments they occupy
each present instants of time they are
not moving in a particular direction
because they are drawn in that direction
or because there is any such thing to
our knowledge of evolutionary progress
they are simply moving like particles at
random in the surrounding forces driven
by the surrounding forces of natural
selection they can move in one direction
and say we are now tracing the movement
of solitaire a very primitive the social
creatures from the upper left-hand
corner all the way through the maze and
if they can come out the take the final
step they will be you social move in one
direction or another moment by moment or
they can stall they can even regress
it's a matter of luck to reach any point
in that maze and that is a cheese by a
series of particular steps each which
each of which may or may not take place
if we look retrospectively in in at the
result in which we are interested in
this case eusociality
then we can speak of the steps as pre
adaptations there is a final step in the
origin of eusociality that event that
has occurred of which we have record
some two dozen times the final step that
takes it across the finals than the
threshold from solitaire or elementary
group to use sociality what is that
final step
I'm gonna show you
this is something I know people have not
thought about it turns out when you look
at the evolutionary steps that have led
up to motion of these cases all the ones
we can track the evolution in that that
final step the final pre adaptation that
takes the species to the threshold and
the evolutionary maze is the building of
a complicated nest defensible from which
individuals a female or a mated pair or
maybe a small simple group forage in
pick up food that they bring home to
feed their matures until the amateurs
reach maturity and in most cases where
that occurs then they all disperse and
begin yet another cycle of individuals
building the defendant knows but in a
few cases these rare cases the young do
not leave they stay and then we have a
eusocial
a primitive Liew social society in a we
see marine shrimp that actually build
nests and sponges in shallow marine
water and on five occasions it's known
independently of these type of Sanel
feeis shrimp have evolved primitive
eusociality the queen is in the middle
the workers around her and one of the
workers is guarding the entrance to
their nest on the right we have the
sweat on B we have the sweat bees have
liquid bees have built nest in the soil
and once again when the young stay with
the parent then the in one short step is
could be by a single mutation silencing
the tendency to disperse we have it
created so this must have happened many
times before because there are large
numbers of species that have made it to
that final threshold but they do not
cross it or if they cross it then the
species goes extinct that mutant form
becomes
extinct and why is that it is because
the group as a whole has to succeed in
competition with solitary individuals
and other groups of other kinds that are
actually in opposition to it in
competition and for reasons we have not
yet investigated but it's now wide open
to do so group selection has to be
powerful in order to come overcome the
effects of individual level selection
individual level selection has been
working for tennis the hundreds of
million years in these evolutionary
lines and the species is in every way
adapted to individual level selected
traits to see it through a successful
life cycle so when the group is formed
that's something new in this manner
there has to be such a powerful
advantage of that group staying together
that it overcomes individual level
selection the Beatles in C are an
example of the wrong way to get the
youth sociality not that they're trying
but the there are large numbers of these
pre social species of organisms
including a lot of beetles in which as
in this case the parent beetles heard
the the larvae along they take care of
them they take them from one food source
to another and never to our knowledge
does a migratory group of this without
the nest without foraging away and
bringing food to the Lord and never has
meant to you sociality so this is a
pretty strict requirement a pre
requirement pre adaptation to move on
whew quite a few of the species are at
the threshold chimpanzees and gorillas
for example as shown here African wild
dogs but they have not taken the final
that so why they have not is a remaining
evolutionary question of very
considerable importance now I'm going to
recent primary literature to trace the
steps that have been worked out by many
scientists to trace the steps of the pre
humans took to create a new social human
in other words went through the pre
adaptations to led from the split
between the pre human and chimpanzee
lion lines some six million years ago
now this is a synthesis as I say of a
great deal of work and I have based it
carefully upon existing peer-reviewed
reports in key journals here is the
first step get out of the trees the
chimpanzees did this and the ideas have
become bipedal and free the hands the
chimpanzees are not really bipedal
they're quadruped Atal they a still
knuckle walk for most of their local
motion but they can stand and walk on
the hind legs but they just didn't do it
the right way
the chimps nonetheless as many of you
know that line were the two species the
chimpanzee and the vulnerable have
achieved an awful lot of advanced
behavior including social behavior they
have cultures in which from troop to
troop or from region to region from
Senegal to Kenya or wherever different
groups have their own cultures that have
they've invented throwing stones or in
this case for example using pieces of
wood or the bones of animals to dig up
tubers but that's it they haven't gone
beyond that this is the habitats in
which the chimp lion has lived all that
time and
which the human minds live and these are
hunters gathering who are showing the
same appearance physical appearance we
are fairly certain and modes of life of
that the the ancestors for all modern
Homo sapiens in the world were following
when the breakout from Africa at sixty
thousand years ago and this is the
habitats in which it occurred the
Savannah and the grassland art epiphysis
we don't have much material on this
creature that live 4.4 million years ago
but here we had a completely bipedal
straight up walking primate the only
thing was that it was it had the still
had the brain size of a chimpanzee this
very likely is an ancestor of the human
line going way back Arta pittacus are
something very close to it in time gave
rise to a whole series of species that
appeared as many as three living in
africa at the same time of the
australopithecines they were erect
clearly at least one was in line to
create homo later on they were
vegetarian they were specialized for
different types of vegetable food and
ways of getting it probably and in
habitats in which they had occurred so
in the typical manner of an adaptive
radiation species multiplied and they
fill different niches again the
australopithecines underwent only a very
slight increase in brain size from the
chimp from the chimp volume 400 percent
of me maybe to 500 cubic centimeter
if say three million years ago et has
landed and looked over the fauna of
Earth and it had seen the
australopithecines striding around on
the African soil eating fruit and
communicating back buying sounds with
each other like chimps they would have
made no special mention note of it but
some three to two million years ago a
remarkable event happened as illustrated
here the brain size after remaining
static for all that period of time
suddenly began to increase and it went
through a steep incline of increase
primarily in the fore of the forebrain
unlike any other evolution in rate of a
complex organ of what we which we know
and they and thus was created eventually
the genus Homo this is what happened
starting 3 to 2 million years ago what
caused this sudden departure one line of
the australopithecines began to eat more
meat started becoming more of a
carnivore we know that from bone
structure from changes in the skull and
the it was pretty clear that they had
changed their diet somewhat from a more
purely carnivorous from a purely
vegetarian diet and even today
chimps if I've got these figures right
chimps get on average about 3 percent 3
percent of their calories from mean
scavenging and from hunting to some
extent they hunt vervet monkeys gangs of
males too but the average consumption
worldwide for Humanity is closer to 1/3
and this is something of this nature has
happened then in this period
and about two and a half million years
ago and it's here that we see the brain
science efficient having increased
substantially and the bone structure of
the face to place it in the genus Homo
no longer in the genus Australopithecus
and we can surmise but have no direct
proof that by this time they were
working out of campsites and bringing
the prey and meat to the campsite and
sharing it there we can surmise that but
we don't know it for sure
we certainly know that it happened by
the time Homo erectus a direct
descendant of the Hammond lines had come
into existence by two million years we
have direct evidence of campsites with
controlled fire not hard to do all you
got to do is pick up burning branches
from lightning struck ground fires which
occur at frequent intervals through the
African savannah and of course they
would have also encountered but in
animals killed by the fire and partly or
wholly cook so that it was easier to
digest and thus the homo skull culture
that they are dentition our gut began to
change to feed on cooked food including
meat here is the nest
that's the campsite where we know they
came and stayed for a long time they
went out from there some went out and
they divided labor in that matter
sixty thousand years ago then after
substantial more revolution within
Africa leading to modern form of Homo
sapiens the breakout occurred from
Africa and that species quickly from
through the Nile corridor and that
breakout resulted in rapid spread across
Asia and on across into New Guinea and
beyond into Australia as we see here
illustrated the first Australians and
this is the way we believe all of our
ancestors looked sixty thousand years
ago something like this they have
evolved to but we've evolved at least in
in skin colour and as most europeans
have and Asians in other ways but I can
say not in cognitive ability it has
demonstrable e about the same the
signature behavior of the groups of the
newly evolved and spreading humans was
aggression between groups and we we
think of the yanomamö of northern
northern South America for example as
being unusually aggressive but that has
been true in intervals of virtually all
human society periods of extreme
aggression as right into history as
William James said history is a
bloodbath
the Mayans depicted their wars and Brian
genocides and sacrifice proudly on the
walls of the caves of Spain and France
back to 32,000 years ago is a large
amount of art that's not ordinarily
displayed in
the art of published of the growth
Charvet and other of the classical cave
art murals there's a lot of graffiti
some of which would not be appropriate
for hanging on your own wall in addition
there's abundant evidence of killings of
people men primarily by spear and this
seems most likely to have been the
depiction of raids vengeance raids
territorial raids occurring frequently
now let me just remind you with a quick
diagram of what individual level
selection is this would be the way it
would look saying the change of bird
color if the environment were such that
a dark blue for a particular bird in
this case it's imaginary example and
there were a series of alleles or
distinct genes that darkened or
lightened the plumage color in an
environment in which the genes were
competing and individuals were competing
with their offspring in regaining
resources including nest sites and food
and so on then we would expect to see
generation by generation a gradual shift
of the genes in the population to those
prescribing darker blue color that's it
simple Darwinism in contrast the
evolution by group selection which is
demonstrable particularly in the social
insects where we have from group
selection which is going on all the time
and some termites are the most warlike
of all known creatures their colonies
are always in conflict and war one
colony will destroy another neighboring
colony if it is able to overcome
and the results of this in part has to
be the amazing spectacular display of
cast of all kinds in the morphology
behavior and the like there is no other
explanation
as Bert holdover and I have pointed out
at length in our book the super organism
it was occurring almost certainly in
human beings as well it was Darwin who
in the Origin of Species embraced group
selection which in recent years has
become disfavored but he saw that this
was how to explain the origin of the
worker caste of ants the only way that
he could explain it that did not become
a serious threat that might destroy his
whole theory of natural selection so he
met a big point of it in the Origin of
Species then in the descent of man
Darwin turned to humans and said the
same thing is happening in humans he
described clearly group selection what
happens is that traits that are under
the control of genetic just prescription
in interaction among individuals from
particularly forms of communication are
but also all other forms of interaction
between the do a social nature are
favored or disfavored by the natural
selection caused by competition of group
against group so this brings us into the
distinction that we are now approaching
it's called multi-level and a individual
selection like the birds occurs when
individuals compete with members of the
same group on the basis of these traits
loop selection of genetic traits occurs
when group
compete with other groups on the basis
of interactions of social individuals
within each group overall individual
selection within groups engenders
selfish behavior allow me to call it sin
and group selection and genders
cooperative behavior how did it come
that human beings began to engage in
group selection that led to advanced
social behavior we have a pretty good
idea from work by cognitive and social
psychologists during the last ten to
twenty years and it is the observation
that human beings have two powerful
clearly instinctual traits that are so
prevalent and so strong and Universal
that we never or rarely think of them as
human traits we just think of them as
being they're like air and water part of
nature the first one is iron tense need
to form groups and we form them easily
sometimes arbitrarily sometimes you're
on a common cause a team sport that can
be based on anything it can be ten
groups but more likely it is groups of
common interest and common geographic
origin and these groups then form and
they are as scientists social
psychologists are shown in experiments
even when they are arbitrarily formed
that is selection are made of teams of
volunteers to belong to a group and
compete games simple games with other
randomly selected individuals among are
betray among volunteers in short order
each group thinks of itself its members
as being smarter and more trustworthy
and this is powerful instinct that we
have to do that and to live by our
groups and to identify ourselves by the
groups and the second powerful influence
that we have is to constantly evaluate
one another human beings are obsessively
interested in other human beings they
spend all of their time very large part
of their time thinking about individuals
as they know and as a psychologist call
it reading intention the ability to read
and tension is developed so much in
human beings that we are geniuses at it
and as a result we can create the social
networks within groups that give us the
largest chance of success and survival
but it also generates while we're doing
it so many of the human traits this form
in per endless permutations the subject
matter of fiction and other literature
and that is all that we can do all that
we intentionally desire to do to form
bonds to form groups to cooperate and
that was the key to cooperate in an in
conflict with other groups and
internally to engage in affection in
bonds and as well as to deceive
manipulate control that's what so much
of human social activity consists of and
we were incest with with doing it those
two are the keys that come from group
selection but they also include what we
call the basic virtues and the
willingness to the altruistic and
self-sacrificing those of you who
followed recent literature and
evolutionary theory may recognize that
this account of the driving force
the origin of human sociality and other
sociality all the other cases i
mentioned is that variants with a
traditional theory of the evolution of
altruistic behavior and eusociality my
kin selection is process opposed product
the measure inclusive fitness the two
years ago two mathematicians of the
first rank Martin Novak and Karina
carnita at Harvard as I showed that the
basic basic assumption of the inclusive
fitness theory are mathematically
unsound and second that the biological
explanations that have been derived from
it to try to explain it by kin selection
are easily or and probably better
explained by multi-level selection and
the kind of just giving you individual
level selection and group selection or
the combination thereof kin selection
suggested or posited that it is groups
of kin that come together that become
altruistic because they can be
altruistic and not lose genes their own
genes prescribing their own behavior
because if they are with a gene with a
close relative a brother I'm talking
about collateral relatives now not all
spring the universal Darwinian
individual level selection it's a
collateral relatives brother and sister
cousins nephew niece and so on then if
they sacrifice some of their longevity
they sacrifice some of their security
and and wealth to support altruistically
these close relatives then the you can
have a group forming and that can grow
by this kind of behavior and the spread
of the genes that promote it into a an
advanced social group
unfortunately that is mathematically
incorrect
and the the mathematical argument after
18 months caused when the British call
it a fluttering of the dovecote the and
you know considerable blowback for those
who were working in that field and using
that theory nonetheless after 18 months
there has been no none have addressed
the mathematical argument there's no
objection to it and second no critique
that I've seen of the alternative
explanations by multi-level selection
and in particularly group selection that
would propose as alternative to those
explanations that have been provided by
kin selection so I've covered this
subject in considerable depth in the
book a costal conquest of Earth and have
interested you can pursue the subject
there and I felt that I needed to tell
you to give you a caveat that in terms
of opinion oh this is not settled but
with the fact that quite a few refused
to accept an alternative again selection
theory means nothing because the science
is not conducted by polls and moreover
the if we have a substantial group of
scholars and other mathematical and
evolutionary theorists who are convinced
that our approach is probably the
correct way in any case if we are right
and we are right the door is the door is
now fully open for a fuller examination
of biological origins of human nature
the applications of pen selection were
very narrow in the scope that they could
make any explanations of sound
convincing I'm going now to move quickly
to a close just by mentioning in passing
other human instincts may or may not be
subject to this type of social
multi-level selection but nonetheless
should persuade us a bit more than we
have been persuaded generally even the
academic community that we do have
irrational behaviors that are the
residue of that long prehistory brought
us to where we are today and also to
persuade you that history can spleen
explain a lot but it is sharply
truncated and stopped at the birth of
literacy and that we have to go on back
and back to understand the origins of
the human condition the history makes no
sense without prehistory and prehistory
makes no sense without biology and it is
here in the relation between biology and
history itself that will be one of the
junctures symbiotic relation between
disciplines and two of the great
branches of learning first I'll just
mention that one of the consequences of
this connection between of the of the
conflict between group selection and
individual level selection is that it is
unstable we are a conflicted species and
we will be
species forever because we cannot go to
either extreme all the way to the
individual level selection that was
dissolve the society not all the way the
group selection that would make us
angelic robots we're going to be caught
suspended in the middle and this is a
good explanation as we have of why human
beings are so fundamentally conflicted
and particularly just within their own
families but in their own group and also
internationally and that maybe if all of
the cases of known new sociality and all
these very different groups of organisms
and we never really gave serious thought
to this before but if all of them were
created the same way and they appear
certainly to have been created the same
way follow the same track for the maze
then it may well be possible that this
is the only way that you can reach a
homeland level of intelligence and
social organization and if that is true
that is a very fundamental constraint on
the way social behavior an advanced
organization and intelligence can be
developed anywhere so maybe that's the
only way that it's ever occurred if it
has for the rest of the universe just
now for the I'm going to pass on to the
origins of intelligence and culture I
cover them in the book but I don't have
time to go into them now
but I just wanted to show you a couple
amazing things that people don't realize
about themselves a result of their
sensory apparatus the constraints on
they're simply a sensory apparatus and
they tend to be irrational I mean
they're beyond conscious control of
these regions designs the ones that
arouse you the most are that's the one
in the center I guarantee you that
that's the case you can see the impact
you know of the brain arousal the
stamping of the alpha wig and this is
quite possibly behind a lot of culture
namely for example in the level of in
complexity and design of pictographs
shown in this Japanese example the
beautiful Punjabi checks the levels of
complexity commonly seen in so-called
primitive art even in modern designers
for example in this magazine or journal
cover some time ago
of the artists has chosen who represent
the brain at that level of complexity
and down at the lower left-hand corner
you will see the logo graph of the
American Academy of Arts and Sciences at
that level now we come to the preferred
habitat many of you may have heard of
this that cross-cultural tests have
shown that when people can choose any
habitation location where they can live
they have their habitation and thus they
have a view out they choose three
features they want to be on the rise
they want to look out over a park park
reading savanna and they want a body of
water next to it and that's what they
will pay extremely high prices to get
regardless of whether there's any
utilitarian value to it it's instinctive
and it's not too much to say for reasons
that I could argue but don't have time
now that it's a residual habitat
professed preference that all animals
display and that is necessary for their
survival and I will clue a clue dwith
this and I'm going to leave it at this
as you read this as to where we go from
here I'm going to be a little bit strong
worded about the forty year the four
decades that we have labored and spun
our wheels with Ken's selection theory
and I'm guilty of that too because in my
own
first books from sociobiology I adopted
it as a good genetic explanation and
those words are that we now have got to
clear the wreckage of kin selection off
the road so we can move ahead and now
that that's being done what I've now
written here it would be much more
likely to come to pass
whether I've actually made any progress
toward an saying Paul Gauguin's three
great questions whether or not this is
likely to be the direction we're going
to take in this era this domain of
evolutionary theory I lead to your good
officers you future scientists and to
the development of history and I thank
you for listening but to me tonight
and okay what's the difference between
you social and social because come on
there's herds and flocks and all kinds
of things that are social yeah you
socially you sort of make be gentle or
softer so it's a little fiercer than
that it's a little more well it just
means true we just use that word to mean
as I said earlier the society that is
based in part upon division of labor
that is altruistic and quality among
competing individuals within the group
that covers two or more generations and
involves the care rearing of the young
cooperatively that's your cell so of
course it's very different than insects
as it is from what it is in humans
because we have this immense overlay of
cultural modification of our behavior
and we have this ability of this amazing
genius of elaborating knowledge and
modulating our behavior accordingly
to our own benefit but we seem to be
relatively short in a lot of the fire of
our activities in actually applying
rationality we have you know where for
one thing this obsession with group
identity as I think hobbles was badly
and we need to form new groups will
always form groups I don't think we'll
ever get away from that we're not going
to have one world with one big
collectivity and lazy ants keep trying
that there's the super organism which
you defined that these colonies become
and then you were mentioning to me
earlier they're super colonies like the
Argentine ants that lately invaded the
west coast what would keep humans from
doing this hooper call anything
we're basically it's all one one social
group and that's earth the Argentine ant
and there are a few other species that
have created super colonies another one
is a fire ant
did this I mean any dude on purpose
that's what they did they changed from
species that have distinct colonies that
are always at war the way ants are and
enter fearsomely kut'r to conduct war
and defend the colony and so on they
went to a super colony by a single
mutation it's been identified in the
fire ant as one that actually silences
the ability to distinguish one colony
from another so they blend together and
also these super colonies have lots and
lots of Queens where ordinarily only one
queen the mother queen is tolerated it's
due to the silencing is due to an
ability to smell or detect the
distinction and colony odors that every
every colony of ants has it has a
peculiar its own peculiar blend of
hydrocarbons and the waxy coating it's
like you know they precise bouquet of a
wine and you've got to be able to have a
very sensitive taste to distinguish it
and identify it and they lose that taste
and they also lose the ability to
recognize that there's more than one
queen so the result is that it just
grows on more and more why isn't then
the world filled with super colonies of
ants instead of wood there he is
why I'll tell you
because super colonies Jorah usually
appear only in disturbed areas where
competition is full with other kinds of
events and when you have a call of a
population or industry there where a
typical local ant community as you get
say in the woodland or a natural metal
would have anywhere from 10 to maybe 30
or 40 species in the North temperate
zone and each one of those species and
it's caught has its colonies that are
with a different armamentarium for
colony defense and the super colony
would simply not be able to deal with
all of them and particularly being
having trouble with its own recognition
of colonies so they can't penetrate
easily and this wasn't shown
experimentally they can't get into
undisturbed environments with natural
colonies variety keeps feeding what
sounds like variety is of the essence
that if you get too much uniformity you
lose your thank you for giving me an
opening to plea for biodiversity I mean
we really need these natural
environments with as many species that
are in normal residence as we can
preserve because the all of the studies
we've made of community organization and
stability in natural communities of
species has shown us that we need lots
of species for insurance for example
when one species goes extinct there will
always be another species that can fill
that niche and the community of species
can go on we need it for resistance to
physical environmental changes most of
these species have homeostatic devices
as they use and we just need to keep a
natural world with a maximum number of
species that naturally coexist with one
another you make a similar case for a
variety of biological humans and of
cultures itself well I do in the book I
for example I'm often asked the question
is or is humanity evolving still we did
go through quite a lot of evolution
right at the time of a break out but it
was mostly had to do with resistance to
disease and the ability to acquire new
food products an independent origin of
adult lactose tolerance in Europe
Eurasia and also in Africa as an example
of that which allowed hurting to become
a primary means of making a living but
most of evolution of what we call
progressive evolution it's just not
occurring we're not getting bigger
brains we're not getting any better
looking but what is happening of
profound importance is that we're
homogenize
where previously the most of human
variation was Geographic you know you
get it from going from one locality to
another we called it racial now people
are intermarrying and travelling
worldwide and they are simply
homogenizing the entire human genome
type where there were previously big
differences between localities but not
much that much within localities now
it's the reverse now there's less a
fewer and fewer real differences from
one place on the world to another and if
we keep the kind of spread that we're
still making transport and intermarriage
theoretically we'll end up with people
in Beijing
and in Stockholm being the same
statistically however as a result of
this we're also expanding enormous ly
the different genetic diversity within
communities meaning that we are creating
a large number of new human genotypes
and that will increase I like that idea
because I think we our species that
depends upon your diversity diversity of
personalities and abilities and and what
we'll get is a lot more of that
diversity and we'll get perhaps new
forms of genius we'll get new forms of
ability maybe someone will run a two
hour marathon and maybe it won't be from
Kenya either a couple questions from
from people here da Theogony my ask an
your social misting the social nesting
step be tested is there short life cycle
species there's near your sociality that
could be pushed there by basically
prompting a the nesting situation and
see if they if they make the job I mean
can we yeah this is this could this be
an experiment that could be run and a
lot of species is on the threshold it
has been you know run your hypothesis on
it and see it was wrong yeah well yes it
has been run and and the results is
extraordinarily interesting the Japanese
started this but some American
investigators have repeated the
experiment you take bees particularly
little sweat bees that form the nest but
they haven't in solitary fashion but
they haven't yet got together or the
offspring don't stay around with a
mother so that they have a little new
social colony and if you force two of
these females together as they're ready
to make their nest into such a small
area that they can only make one nest
then one of them start digging and
starts when this becomes the dominant
female
and the other then comes in and helps
her and when the nest is built the one
that start digging at the dominant
becomes the queen and lays the eggs and
the other one goes out foraging this is
what I call spring-loaded adaptation or
spring-loaded pre adaptation I think you
guys explain the spring loading is this
is a spring-loaded means that you have
the tendency to do something that can be
actually under other circumstances a pig
evolutionary jump but because of other
traits you have you are preset to do
something that takes that jump if you
make another kind of change in other
word these bees are territorial that
means that they already have built in
aggression territoriality is a form of
dominance
you know you get too close to my
territory and I know I'll chase you and
you you yield because this is the
strategy in that game if the yields stay
with your turret or even a small
territory so it's that behavior which is
just about universal insects of all kind
that are built in esta tend to be very
territorial translates when you force
them just use the same nest into one now
dominating the other and saying in
effect this is my territory you're the
worker and you actually can create you
social colonies simple colonies in the
laboratory I'm wondering so you've made
the math case Novak as Martin Novak has
made the math case that kin selects an
inclusive fitness doesn't really play
out you've made a lot of the biological
argument that it doesn't play that way
in the species including us
there's multi-level selection invite
mathematical depiction course is going
to be too vague to actually not only out
an equation let's follow
the kin selection was too vague okay we
went for it's decades without any
mathematician trying to plunge to take
it to the bottom of the assumptions to
find the consequences and when that was
done it was found to be unsound invalid
in the case of natural it's a very good
question in the case of multi-level
selection we're returning now in a way
to a system of genetic change it's much
more palpable and measurable both as a
group level at an individual level and
there already is a very strong and
well-developed
field of population genetics prepared to
deal with genes frequencies of change as
you have different advantages given to
group versus group and individual versus
individual I think that I will see a
whole new mathematical theory of
multi-level selection develop that's
more realistic because there will be a
lot of biology behind it which shows us
the states these unstable states and
this is one of the most profound aspects
of this if it is correct and I think it
is correct that we are permanently
unstable we're permanently conflicted
and we just as we we don't have any
ideal society or real ancient who to
move toward what we have is a muting
self-understanding and a muting of the
conflicts that come in rationally out of
that instability and lack of
understanding of what altruism is where
it comes from why we are the way we do
why we worry all the time why we gossip
all the time and all that we need to
understand ourselves not as errant
primates that just haven't found its way
to an ideal social condition quite the
contrary
always gonna be this way and we just
somehow got to do it through self
understanding and through conflict
resolution and mechanisms for more
cooperation and tolerance so your
colleague at Harvard Steven Pinker came
out with this book the better angels of
our nature and there's a question here
from Jack Sawyer what part of evolution
what partners evolution play and the
decline of violence cruelty and
injustice that that Steve is documented
pretty well basically through human
history and actually all the way back to
the chimps and in his version oh well we
may be overall or certainly had a
dramatic decrease or and we'll have a
more the future of national or you know
big war but I haven't read his book yet
can you tell me if he really documented
it by including civil war love it is
documented up the wazoo he's got the
same pictures you have people with
spears in them okay well if well
actually that's the trend we would hope
for and it'll be interesting to see you
know does that the question basically
implies that it's not just culture
there's something genetic that is there
cuz you've written long ago about the
gene-culture co-evolution
you know that's another so this sort of
things should show up over time and I
think he refers to it in the genome that
this D violin sonata
is being selected for probably in a
group selected fashion among other
things because your point is that groups
that cooperate well beat groups that
don't cooperate so well and this is all
part of it yeah well we want a lovable
humanity but without with another the
price of are all becoming wimps
now maybe because you're an ant guy
you've been all of your story has been
very violent yeah you know this group
beats that group and basically chews
them up and eats them but a lot of
Darwinian Fitness has to do with just
you know what group makes the best use
of the available resources to you turn
ins to the next generation most most
natural selection occurs that way who
uses the resources best and fastest is
the species that can displace other
species and that's one of the reasons
for the success of the ends because they
have really a super organ it's not the
super colony we were talking about
Argentina has a super colony but super
organism like ant really are operating
like one big organism and they have
distributed intelligence so that even
though their instinctive ants know a lot
they could remember a lot honeybees some
ants can remember the location in a
complicated environment of five sites
where they can get food and they can
remember the time of the day when they
get the food they go out at the right
hour they do things like that
pretty smart an ant can run learn a maze
rat maze but it takes a lot longer it
takes twice the time and so on so they
learn these simple things and what you
have is a bunch of ants you know the
ones that you step on thoughtlessly
these answer out there and their Scouts
many of them they know that part of the
territory and they are searching for it
through it and others in other parts of
the territory know their part and so on
and they are equipped then to find food
or encounter an enemy scout and get back
fast and then bring others out also they
have a network of security around it and
also there are ants very familiar with
the nursing process with building a part
of the nest and so on this distributed
intelligence and bits of memory that
improve their performance enormous ly
enhances the competitive power
productivity and the competitive
strength of a colony over an individual
organism there's controversy around
group selection what would it take to
disprove group selection it's it's got
to be a falsifiable hypothesis to be
science
so as the science moves forward now with
your encouragement into the area of
looking at the population biology
hormones are shifting in relation to the
things and forces you're talking about
what would be an indicator that this
isn't working out I believe that one
well let me let me come back just a kin
selection and show you an example that
just proved it long ago and this came in
the textbooks and some of you sitting
here may have suffered through having to
memorize this false proof of a false
theory was it said the kin selection
must be true because most of the cases
of the RG sociality you know this
altruistic organize or
raishin occur in the Hymenoptera and the
Hymenoptera have a form of sex
determination called haploid diploid
that means unfertilized eggs become
become male fertilized eggs become
female and also that means then that
workers do not have a father but they
have a grandfather and workers are
morkul you can do the math workers more
closely related in shared genes to each
other than they are to mother the mother
and that it seemed that this is where
almost all the cases of eusociality had
originated to me this was Newtonian it
was a marvelous demonstration that I'm
an opera bees ants wasps were where most
of this action was taking place and they
did indeed have this quality the sisters
forming the worker caste were acting as
though they were favoring the closest
kin unfortunately has searched for other
you social species spread in so many
diplo deployed e ones that didn't fit it
or discovered that it no longer became
significant thus in this sense this is a
retro dicta the kind of retro addictive
a test that we use in a lot of
evolutionary biology oh that was
abandoned and we had to just sort of
adjust the whole theory so that in
concluded that fact was does not fit
that was a test
it failed that didn't stop us though
they kept on believing it we have yet to
develop rigorous tests of group
selection in the field except to say
that by common observation we know that
colonies with certain traits in the same
species such as larger colonies colonies
that
that can prevail consistently so that
rapid growth of colonies clearly gives
that superiority we also know that you
can take away the soldier caste and that
colony losses and combat things like
that
I think gradually we'll be able to test
it quite well
furthermore this whole of this matter of
the so far invariant pathway to pre
dictations leading up to the origin of
eusociality is by itself a strong piece
of of evolutionary evidence yeah you got
some nice mechanisms or I like
especially the single allele that
basically silences a particular behavior
like this well that's an easy jump to
make one of the things that will be done
now I mean as we proceed you and I were
talking about the amazing advances in
genetic engineering you know what
they're combined with this warp-speed
genomic studies that are ongoing is that
we will and I know others are some
genetics are doing it now with social
insects oh and this the wait for them is
now cleared by this new theory there's
much clearer way of formulating the
problems and asking the right question
they're looking for those genes that
actually caused the step they call
spring loading and it caused the the
altruistic response under certain
circumstances and there will come a time
when human genetics reaches a point
where we'll be able to get some idea of
the genetic basis in those personality
traits which include empathy or
aggressiveness or assertiveness versus
reticence they're a series of
personality traits which are precisely
measured and identical versus fraternal
twins studies indicates that there's
heritability of as much as one half and
many of these personality traits
eventually we'll get to the bottom of
those there'll be multiple genes but we
will learn what makes us
human in these particularly respect
let's leads to a couple of questions
from several people on basically that
where are we going level Bruce Miller
says are there levels of eusociality not
yet attained by humans that might be
driven by more of this kind of selection
of byron ask if you sociality arose late
do you think a larger scale organization
or evolutionary scheme lies in the deep
future what's the future of eusociality
that's the science but they actually
well I really think that we're going to
it's you know leave the the ancient
solution we're just going to find out
how to get along together that's not
basically we're going to put a lot more
emphasis on conflict resolution I think
we're going to put a lot less emphasis
upon idealistic ideologies you know the
think they have a end point you know
that's all you managed to do moving on I
think there's going to be in spite of
what's happening in the United States
right now I think there will be a
decline in organized religions but
especially with reference not
transcendent or spiritual seeking but
rather the creation stories that's a
killer the creation stories I get set in
stone and people then belong to groups
and they feel they have to have complete
fidelity to that creation story of their
tribe and if you question any of the
creation story you know like something
like evolution then they are offended
and they get hostile why because you're
attacking their tribe we need to get
we're going to see a decline I think in
religion creation stories religious
rhetoric you wrote a very friendly book
to Christians in America it's out in the
lobby called the creation where you say
pastor at the beginning of each chapter
and you're basically talking to
Christians a very friendly fashion to
join forces and basically efforts toward
cots
raishin and other such things the end of
this book you're pretty tough on
religion and those people you're sweet
to in the last book you basically don't
give any well if you read variation
that's the book in which I appeal to the
religious and particularly evangelicals
who make up 40% of Americans I said
right from the start I'm an atheist
I have Anatoli different worldview from
you and I described what they believe
your fundamental issue believes
literally in the Bible but I think that
if we sat down together at a table we
could become friends and talk about it a
lot and that maybe we would then come to
a conclusion that we are natural allies
and we can address a question or a
problem of immense importance to us all
regardless of our worldview and that's
the creation I was willing to use the
word creation
you know the biodiversity of Hawaii oh
and that was the argument I made and I
got a lot of cooperation I got invited
by the leadership of the Mormon Church
says visit and talk about it at length
and I visited a number of strongholds of
the Southern Baptist Convention and met
and religious leaders it didn't go very
far because I don't think most people
really you know even if they agreed with
you they don't that's particularly if
you've been your favorite evangelical in
many and Christians other Christian
sects some of them this earth is not
anything you need to be concerned about
this is just a way station and the far
right believes that you should not worry
about the environment in fact the book
of Revelation written like the john the
divine showing incidentally all the
signs of paranoid schizophrenia without
it's a theme I develop in the book and
it'll get me in trouble I know but
that's it it looks like the ramblings of
us paranoid schizophrenic off his meds
but the fact was that many of the
extreme religious believe you know that
the creation story makes them believe
and the book of Revelation lord help us
makes them believe that we're just here
for a short period of time Humanity is
that what we should be doing is not
worrying about species we should be
worrying about saving souls the
important thing is to save as many which
mean bring them into the tribe of
southern baptism or other forms these
angelic ilysm how do I survive in
Alabama I'm very popular there and one
of the reasons I'm popular is that I
love them and I've just written a
history of South Alabama and I've
written a novel based on it I respect
all of it
and besides it's a mix of sizes just
like California it's there are a lot of
people who are highly educated and not
you know strong right-wing
fundamentalism besides once you've been
saved and I went under the water when I
was a kid then they expect that before
you die you will come back into the fold
and I'm not going you know and I'm not
to be dismissed easily because I still
have time you know there's some couple
questions and then basically the future
of Ed Wilson William Petry asks if you
have advice for young whippersnappers on
how to stay active and engaged for many
decades for example you have you're
pretty busy for an 82 year old and I
understand you're working on a book
letters to young scientists whether to a
young scientist I'm writing
right now you know it's on why we
desperately need you if you were ready
if you really want to go into science
and technology whether you're in high
school college or graduate school go for
it and I tell them how to succeed and
what science is and how to make a career
and what science real innovation really
is and you tell a lot of succeed for six
decades do you tell them how to succeed
for six decades how to keep going how do
you yeah keep going exactly how does a
scientist stay fresh
how do you stay fresh watch this right
genes few alcoholic beverages love the
outdoors but for the one that you know
I'll say to my fellow octogenarians
everyone over 80 ratio we have many oh
there's an octogenarian thank God so my
fellow octogenarians and I say never
retire that's the important thing I
don't know if you agree with me you
can't you can step out you know of that
post masters job you had you can stop
brain surgery especially if you have the
tremors but find other work you know
that you've always wanted to do and keep
going even if it's a hard thing to do
sometimes it's a little harder when you
get older to get up in the morning or to
face a challenge you know or to log a
piece of luggage through a crowded a
crowded Airport jammed with irritating
badly dressed it dressed twenty year old
[Applause]
on the other hand
the 80 year olds if they're still
functioning got their health basically
you've got a lot of canny savvy street
smart experience to draw on so when do
you want to make something happen
there's a lot of shortcuts you know now
yes make happen yes I people respect
older people you know it's there are
places I knew I'd crossed the threshold
when young lady started opening the door
for it but the moments of triumph for me
was when I arrived in one of my
expedition to the island of Vanuatu that
used to be new forever Jesus was last
December November sorry I took a group
for these studies the answer in the
mountains of Vanuatu never before
explored and we want why I needed to
know what the role of Vanuatu is in
Island jumping from Australia to New
Caledonia to Fiji and or down from the
Solomon island so we had to find out was
on Vanuatu and when I got back in the
villages the word spread that there was
an 80 year old man coming to visit some
I'm not sure the number of Vanuatu ins
and southwest Pacific who lived to be 65
is under 1% and to have an 80 year old
come visit them I was treated with great
courtesy a lot more than I get in Boston
you know Stuart I think we're losing it
here okay I'll raise one question that
is this future-oriented which is you
said and way back in the book naturalist
I think that if you were starting over
in biology now that you would be
focusing on microbial ecology and that
was before shotgun sequencing of buckets
of seawater and metagenomics and all
that kind of stuff why why microbes why
microorganisms I can see it coming no
you know dart microorganisms including
bacteria and archaea of the lark dark
matter of the biological world we know
maybe ten thousand species still only
kind of you can pick up one gram of soil
that's you know the five cent pieces
five grams
pick up one gram of garden soil you've
got one billion bacteria in there
representing five or six thousand
species all of them unknowns it's not
fortunately all three million species
have been estimated to be in one ton of
garden soil they're all distinct genomes
doing their own thing
requiring certain conditions of pH
nutrients surrounding they each have an
evolutionary history our lives depend on
them what do you mean a lot depends on
oh how the soil works how the atmosphere
works stuff like that what about that
one of the ten trillion bacteria living
in symbiosis of your body three pounds
of you know I don't work this is one of
the amazing new developments well of
course the soil would die I mean
everything would die if the bacteria
died I mean the material and energy
cycles would just halt
however for pure science the study the
world of microorganisms is just an
amazing frontier and we now have the
technology for it you just mentioned
Swift sequencing you can see
an entire bacterium genome in just a
couple of hours now but the we know that
the human body I've just attended a
conference in Washington was 10 men you
know it's a medical branch of Ted this
super technology organization and there
were the three speakers there were all
it was amazing
molecular biologist selves out of
microbiology they were all talking of
evolutionary biology and ecology and
other you know so many molecular
biologists until a few years ago thought
well that was for dummies right oh yeah
that was an old-fashioned biology now
there suddenly dawned on them that this
is where they need to be going one for
example described the intricacies of our
dependence interdependence with bacteria
the coevolution of our bacterial flora
that the 500 or more bacteria in the
mouth and esophagus are there to protect
themselves and protect you from
pathogenic bacteria etc etc etc but one
speaker from Penn say his name slipped
my mind is leading a group that is
probably one of them number who is
beginning to address this question of
the dire danger of antibiotic hardening
of of pathogenic bacteria so that we
can't keep dousing them with antibiotics
and get away with it I'm gonna run out
of antibiotics as an arms race that we
may lose so now there's a great deal of
talk without even knowing what these
muscles bacteria are of developing
theories of evolutionary biology and
from ecology of creating a balance of
protective bacterial symbionts that we
already have with pathogens just like
invasive species that are coming in and
destroying you know helping to destroy
our
natural ecosystem we we should click on
diseases microorganism calls diseases as
being an invasion of our ecosystem of
alien species so we need to build up our
nature and hold our natural microbial
flora in the same way that we need to
build up or allow to continue to exist
our natural ecosystems that protect our
environment interesting to see this way
of medical science now going there you
have it there's a great deal of science
yet to come as we just saw a tiny sample
of a great deal of Ed Wilson yet to come
it seems thank you for coming tonight
[Music]
thank you very much ok thank you very
much
[Music]
[Music]
you